oh there's so many places to take this I
do think it's interesting that the media
when a president goes somewhere they
have to cover it moderate Joe is back
remember moderate Joe this is moderate
Joe it's a learning experience will soon
be a quickly forgotten one but to his
defense I've always said this better
late than never which is also the motto
for Joe's morning BM but it's good I
just hate the fact
that they act like this was a hard thing
to do like he's got a full plate the
only thing he has on his plate is jello
fact is he's not taken a connecting
flight like out of Chicago he's not
going through TSA and LaGuardia he has
his own plane what took him so long and
I think it's fair to say and you're
right arresting migrants why how could
that be because they're illegal you're
not supposed to say that until the
president comes to town and then
suddenly they become illegal they
weren't illegal before so this so the
laws do not apply for the people that
live there only when the president
arrives that's garbage the law should be
enforced when everybody's there even if
the laws suck and I have an analogy and
I think it might be better than your
grandmother one I think it's better
let's hear it go for it the Biden
cleanup is just like what lousy tenants
do when they move out in order to save
their deposit right you know to get the
Fresh coat of paint over the blood
stains to go to they go to Albertsons
and rent the Giant special vacuum yeah
that like that
shakes up hair and teeth but the worst
thing about this is is that he's doing
it out in the open we're all watching
this we're the landlords and we're
seeing him do this we're watching the
whole theater as you say this is all
like drama and then when anybody asks
him all everybody's going to say is what
do you mean look around it's spotless
everything's in place the Border it's
efficient everything's going going crazy
and he'll get away with it because the
media doesn't care Oh on I think it was
on Friday he blamed the murder of a
police officer on April 2nd you know
three months after January 6th on
January 6th he the killing of Billy
Evans was by a radical uh Nation of
Islam follower
ran them over in a car and he blamed it
on insurrectionism and I think it was
only the New York Post that covered that
so he's going to be able to actually
walk away with this because the media
will to answer your question in a
long-winded way we'll do whatever he
wants so I actually just moved out of an
apartment and I did a lot of touch-ups
and the new tenants have complained
because good enough and now I might have
to what were your touch deposits I'm
curious paint touch-ups but they said
there was a lot of holes in the plaster
that required like spackling
before you came
yeah I don't think he could spackle
Jessica it is interesting for a
president to not be curious as to why
does everyone think that my Department
of Homeland Security secretary should
resign I mean there are it's there's
multiple calls for it from across the
government obviously it's the Border
towns in particular or border states
saying like this guy is not doing his
job but Joe Biden's like I think he's
good
well you have to wonder what's going on
behind the scenes in this we know that
Joe Biden pays attention to what's going
on what people are saying about him we
know that he's expressed concerns about
Kamala Harris's performance and been
angry that it seems to be bringing down
the whole kind of reputation of the
administration that she's a weak Link in
that
um so I'm sure that he is concerned
especially heading into now a
republican-controlled Congress that he
might be facing impeachment hearings
with secretary mayorkis whatever
investigations are going to do into him
and his family and I know we're going to
talk about that later in the show but it
does feel to me and I appreciate that
Greg said better late than never not The
Poop part of that but just the general
political point for The Poop part I
believe that truly and the audience
knows that that is the thing you feel
most passionate about
um stop moving the goal posts on it
right people said go to the Border he
went to the Border you know four hours
okay what do you want six hours he's
walking around he was meeting the people
who are actually patrolling there he
didn't accuse anyone of whipping any
migrants right he said what do they need
they need more money I'm going to get
them the money that they need you should
apologize to them you brought it up no
more goal post moving until the B blocks
don't Republicans accuse them of
whipping yeah okay we don't have we
don't have a comparison for that Jessica
and you brought it up so I have to just
interject and say that's not a goal post
mover that was a requirement of the
president who demeaned uh actual
American citizens which presidents
aren't supposed to do and even you would
agree to that I would just one thing
quickly
um
so that sheet that paper that Abbott
delivered to him and had like five
demands on it and I would say that
Governor Abbott is very good at these
kinds of
stunts frankly when you look at what was
actually listed as the things that he
wanted them to happen so the first thing
is something that no president has ever
done before Republican or Democrat so to
actually read the law that in such a way
that everyone should be detained versus
paroleing anyone how is Governor Abbott
thinking that we're going to detain even
if we had a million less migrants then
this request of fully enforced title 42
that's happening plus the fact that
Biden now has a deal with Mexico also
Biden should aggressively prosecute
illegal entry and also expel everyone I
don't think that's possible at the same
time if you'd like to prosecute someone
they have to be in your country all
right so grandstanding Governor Abbott
I mean does it count if you go to the
border and you completely eliminate
something with a Lie by erasing the
problem from the streets of El Paso and
acting like that's the issue I mean if
you want to a lesson in government
propaganda 101 look at exactly what they
did ahead of Joe Biden's visit to to
this place he went to a processing
center didn't meet with any actual
migrants to ask them about maybe what
what's happening at the border they
completely moved out the town and it's
disrespectful to the border patrol and
that's why morale is down but it's also
disrespectful to the Democrat officials
in El Paso who've been begging him to go
see the problem I mean this is not
acceptable from the federal government
to go in and wipe this away and act like
this is actually the picture of what's
Happening that is a lie that is not true
just like saying the agents which the
migrants that was also a lie that they
continue to perpetuate because they
haven't apologized for it looking
forward the National Security adviser
Jake Sullivan was asked today about
President Biden's meeting with Mexican
president he didn't bring up the word
cartel a single time but he did bring up
the issue of climate change and the
bigger picture here is that the Mexican
Government is actually very corrupt they
are in bed with the cartels which is why
whenever we talk about going into Mexico
or doing what Congressman Matt Walsh
once wants to do Waltz wants to do with
allowing there to be military force that
we can use against the cartels Mexican
government gets really touchy and says
well it's about our sovereignty oh
really it's all about you guys it's not
about the Mexican Government it's about
going after the cartels be a great
question and that's exactly why they
don't want to go after it and I'm
telling you if they don't get under
control you're seeing American citizens
going to the Border getting paid off by
the cartels to do their work it will
bleed into other aspects like government
officials and it will be just like
Mexico along the border which cartels
already have control of I felt like it
was as if a president showed up six
months after a natural disaster and said
wow it's really bad yeah I thought maybe
we should do something here good thing
that came and learned all about it